was mir aber dabei grundsätzlich nicht
gegessen ich erwarte auch
bundesregierung dass wir insgesamt eine
aktivere migrationspolitik machen in der
hinsicht dass wir auf der einen seite
ganz viele menschen bei uns haben die
sich hier gut integriert haben wir aber
ein unsicheren status haben kein
vernünftiges aufenthaltsrecht in große
probleme haben am arbeitsplatz und auch
was ihre weitere zukunft steuerung
angeht menschen die uns wirklich
bereichern und auf der anderen seite
haben wir auch einen teil von leuten die
unsere gesellschaft wirklich brutal
belasten wie jetzt aktuell dieser fall
oder wenn ich da erinnern da von zwei
jahren da habe ich bin sehr sehr viele
und sehr viele öffentliche begleitung im
damaligen ehemaligen bin laden richter
sah nach tunesien abgeschoben das war
auch unglaublich schwierig also hier
müssen gesehen dass wir taktisch
cleveren lösungen dass wir auf der einen
seite die hinten die anständig sind hier
auch mit einem wirklich vernünftigen
aufenthaltsstatus belohnen und auf der
anderen seite diejenigen die sich hier
nicht an recht und gesetz halten dann
auch wirklich konsequent aus